اليس من السخف التبشير بان بكين صارت تهدد
المجال الحيوي الامريكي في الشرق الاوسط
لكن في المقابل اليست دخول الصيني على خط
الازمات في الشرق الاوسط مؤشرا قويا على
ان العالم بدا يتغير فعلا اليس دليلا على
بدايه عالم متعدد الاقطاب هل باتت الصين
تهدد النظام الدولي الذي تقوده امريكا بعد
وساطتها الناجحه بين ايران والعرب
للاسف الواقع يطول اننا لازمنا نعيش زمن
القطبيه الاحاديه وسوف تستمر ونستمر على
هذه الحاله على الاقل بالمنظور لمده 50 او
اكثر عزاء الوحيد انه هذا القطب الواحد
الذي يقود العالم هو نعم قطب احادي ولكن
في بنيته نظام تعددي النظام الدولي يتجه
نحو التعدديه القطبيه الاقتصاديه وهذا ما
تعبر عنه الارقام التي يكشفها بنك الد
وليست الصين البنك الدولي يقول ان حجم
الاقتصاد الصيني هو 18 تريليون دولار
الاقتصاد الامريكي هو بين
23 التريليون دولار الاقتصاد الاتحاد
الاوروبي هو يقارب الاقتصاد الصيني بمقدار
18 تريليون دولار لكي تستطيع ان تنافس
الصين امريكا لازم يكون عندها مقومات
للمنافسه بالاقتصاد امريكا رقم واحد
بالمؤشرات الاقتصاديه كلها ايضا بالارقام
21 تريليون حجم الدخل الامريكي بينما
الصين لا زالت 17 بالعسكره رقم الاول عدد
القواعد السلاح ميزانيه الدفاع الامريكيه
تقريبا تريليون
بالاساطير حامله الطائرات عدد الجنود
الترسان النوويه
بالدبلوماسيه 181 سفاره حول العالم 254
بعتها حول العالم
200,000 موظف وزاره الخارجيه
بالسياسه مسيطره على القرار السياسي
العالمي بعد الحرب الاوكرانيه اصبح هناك
حاجه للتعبير عن هذا التنوع والتعدديه
الاقتصاديه لتجنب العقوبات الامريكيه
ولتجنب السياسه الامريكيه العدائيه تجاه
هذه التعدديه هي تحاول ان تحطم النموذج
الاوروبي الاقتصادي من خلال يعني توريط
اوروبا في الحرب الاوكرانيه ومن خلال الذي
شجعت عليه
شركتها
للخروج من الاضعاف الاتحاد الاوروبي
محاوله ايضا خلق صراعات في تايوان وتوريط
الصين واضعاف اقتصاديا والحد من نفوذها
عبر العقوبات الصين منافس ولكنها منافس
صنع في امريكا الصين
عام 1990 قبل ما تنفتح عليها امريكا طبعا
الانفتاح بدا من 71 لكن
الانفتاح الحقيقي او سياسه الاحتواء بدات
بالتسعين كانت الصدر شحاطات بلاستيك الان
وصلت الى ما وصلت لاحتواء امريكا مع الصين
واللي فرضتها على حلفائها وعاطتها تفضيلات
تجاريه خلت الصين تصل الى ما وصل هل فعلا
يعني يمكن ان نصدق بان الصين بدات يعني
تقتحم المجالات الحيويه للولايات المتحده
وخاصه في الشرق الاوسط مجرد انه الصين
بتواسطت بين السعوديه وايران خلص الصين
اكلت امريكا كلام مضحك يعني بصراحه الصين
عينت وزير دفاع عليه عقوبات من امريكا لا
يعتبر هذا تحدي للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه زياره الرئيس الصيني لروسيا في
ذروه الحرب الاوكرانيه وفي ذروه الربيع
ايضا مؤثر على التحدي الصيني للسياسه
الامريكيه الصين
تعرضت لهجمه امريكيه تراد من خلالها في
مناطق نفوذ الصين يراد من خلالها توريط
الصين بصراعات
والمحاصرتها محاوله امريكا ان تنشر مجموعه
من التحالفات الاقتصاديه والامنيه لمحاصره
الصين والحد من نمو الاقتصادي ان مشكله
امريكا مع الصين هناك عجز تجاري اقتصادي
بين الصين والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ويجب المعالجه من خلال العقوبات نسبه
النمو في التجاره المتبادليه بين المنطقه
العربيه والصين نمت بمقدار اربع مرات في
15 عام الماضيه من 100 مليار دولار الى
نصف تريليون دولار الصين اذا تريد بالفعل
ان يكون لها شان تفعل مثل ما سويت امريكا
تحرر محيط الاقليمي تفرض سيطرتها على
التايوان تفرض سيطره على هونج كونج تحرر
الجزر من اليابان او المناطق الثانيه
الجزر في الفلبين تبسط نفوذها وسيطرتها
على بحر الصين اللي الان بحر الصين عباره
عن ملعب الاساطير الامريكيه تقول للصين
ضعيفه عسكريه لكن لديها حليف نووي قوي هو
روسيا لا استطيع ان اقول لك انه العالم
سيتغير في الغد ولكن اقول ان العالم بدا
يتغير